[Music]
it's not possible to have a good yields
of soft shop without pollination
a hand pollination no preparing to get
the collected the pollen grain
or one flower and the male stage
in the main stage we can see that we are
getting some answers and this enters it
is impregnated with the pollen grain
this yellowish color that you can see we
can go through this flower
into this flower we can observe that it
is it is the female stage
so in this female stage I need
to transfer
the pollen grain from this
from this brush to the flower for
example I pouch it in the recipients it
will be full of pollen grain and I or
your transfer this pollen grain to
the flower with one hand I tried to open
the flower
to expose
the female part
the female part of the flower
and after that I put
my brush with pollen grain in contact
with the female part the stigma I do it
Crossing and that's all it is pollinated
this flower will continue
developing but developing only inside
these flowers or they were pollinated
maybe some five something days ago and
they continue in this with this
formation with this appearance for 60
days for about two months
and after that fruits will begin
developing
and with the development of the fruits
we can say that we have to protect these
fruits
foreign
[Music]
this fruit
just after 60 days of the pollination
the fruits begin to develop we can see
the spine that they appear to develop
to separate one from another and this is
the moment of protecting these fruits
because now it's fruits and from this
time it is possible to have infection
with the city border the number one
insect in the world to Source up so from
this phase to when through it it be the
size
the the
the silver can attack so we have to
protect at this phase because if you
protect when fruit is large one it will
not work it will not avoid the the
problem so I put the fruits one or two
fruits together
I protect it with
this this protection
with this bag
this protection should be kept
at least during two more months
now it is protected in this case means
that the past the silver has no capacity
of getting into this uh this uh this
environment because they are protected
with this net with this this material so
I will keep this fruit here during two
modern months at least and after that I
take out this protection and the food
continue developing and naturally the
the insect is not capable anymore to
produce any kind of damage the seeds is
not do not permit the of a position of
the female insect
[Music]
now let's talk something about pruning
pruning is very important in search of
production is a a practice that you have
practice that you have to adopt if you
want to get good results if if you
wanted to get a better control of
diseases and also to help you to
pollinate to protect the fluids with
pecking and also if you during the
moment of spraying against some insects
some diseases and also during the time
of of harvesting so the pruning is very
important you have to open the center of
the search up tree in order to get some
sunlight inside every day and also to
permit the circulation of air so
aeration should be here either you
reduce the problems of diseases and also
will help us to make other practice for
example in this case it was pruned here
this Branch was spoons this also
disorder that this Center was also
pruned here we have other branches that
was also pruned because it was growing
in this direction I need to keep it open
and after pruning we can do it with a
saw we can do it with a Shear in this
case of new suits that usually appear
after pruning we have also to eliminate
it we have to eliminate it in order to
in order to avoid
heavy
closing again the central part of the
canopy so we can do it
every every
branch that suit that is growing we have
to eliminate it
when you do it once twice or three times
after that we can see that it you do not
it will not
appear no new suits again because you
you're reducing its Force its strongness
over this material so this is what we
have to do
another thing that we have to understand
that every time that this plant is
growing
in the height for example more than
three meters in height
or more than a 10 feet in height I have
to put like this plant here for example
when this Branch it is very high I
should cut it
I should cut it
I should
cut it to avoid growing and closing
again with one tree like this in at this
this height I can make all the practices
that this plant will need
like pollination
sprays packing harvesting and so on so I
have to maintain this source of tree
with pruning continuously
because it's the way that we can
increase yield and we can have fruits of
God of good quality
foreign
we have to take a look on the spines and
the color of the skin to see if it is
ready to to be harvested in this case
for example we take a look on the skin
you can see some change in the color of
the skin and especially when you do that
when you cut
you take this spine and you force it you
see that you broke easily it becomes
soft at this stage and also the
operation of harvesting should be done
with a shear and you have to be a good
care so you have to put your Shear near
the the pedal nearly stock near the
fridge near the fruit and Cuts Like This
Way
you can cut it this way and the stock
should remain on the branch because it's
important because in this Zone in this
site it will continuous producing new
flowers it's very important to get in
One Tree like search up to get the site
like this one where we can install a
flower Bud like this one it means that
we have produced or harvested one foot
in this site at this region you can see
this car we have a fruit that we
harvested some months ago it means if it
is well harvested we can get at this
site a lot of new flowers flowers button
it is very important because it means
that in this during many many years we
can produce flowers and fruit every
sites and we have to prune to stimulated
new sites like these new buds like this
one in this position in this position in
this position like this one in this
position like here it will help us to
increase more and more fruits flowers
and fruits the following years it will
help us in increasing yield and fruits
quality
[Music]
traditionally people use both organic
matter and also fertilize chemical
fertilizers you can use both okay but if
you say no I don't want to apply
chemical material no problem but you
have to apply a lot of organic matter
it's very important to apply because
there is good response for social trip
to what we apply organic matter and also
you have to consider that when do you
prune when you prune one three of salsa
you are we estimate that you are you are
putting four to eight tons per acre of
leaves and branches you can see after
two or three years that the root system
goes through this material
superficially with very nice results
and also when you have opportunity you
can use your warm compost to be bio
fertilizer and so on in this case for
example you can see related to to
nutrient cycling
Observer for example in this
the source of tree it was pruned all the
leaves and branches should be put
together Under The Canopy under the
shade of the canopy but you should not
put fruits
please never put fruits small one bigger
one natural fruits never put fluids in
this situation on leaves and breakfasts
never fruits why because fruits usually
develops and track noses call It pottery
code
is the most important disease that we
have in salsa
[Music]